allora partiamo dal presupposto che
giochi partiamo dal presupposto che
giochi come questo non dovrebbero
esistere siccome sono passati dei secoli
da quando ho giocato l'ultimo farina del
freddy's per dire ho scoperto che è
uscito jolly 3 che dal nome non c'entra
una sega però vi assicuro che centra
cofanetti freddy's quindi new game new
game ma che perfetto level sempre la
giornata positiva quando scopriamo
giochi belli ha però qua ti fa vedere
voi ci son finiti lì c'è un falso
chiamato jolly alla madonna che grafica
ma con una musica me non si litiga avrei
apprezzato di più
per ora c'è qualcuno arriva tokamachi na
li per farsi prendere gli infarti cioè
questa persona è un deficiente
ci tengo a mettere in chiaro che
qualcosa sono riusciti in una materia
ho sempre odiato quelli che parlano
l'inizio di fermentare di stato perdo
uguale anche se mi spieghi cosa devo
fare quindi non me lo so spiegare
mezzanotte dove arrivano le 6 del
mattino ciao zio
allora mi ha detto che è molto carino
salve è molto carino come gioco ci fai
da te il freddy scusa se resteremo siamo
il computer che è gigantesco rispetto
agli altri giochi normali noi io sono
qua a la ventola e attiva ma esattamente
sventola cosa devo fare
che bello quando schifo i tutorial pro
non sai che cosa devi fare cos'è sta
roba dio quindi va beh per adesso niente
di strano comunque non c'è scritta e
l'ora c'è l'orario che ore sono
non c'è scritto non c'è scritto che ore
sono come faccio a sapere che ore sono
se voglio vincere la partita non lo so
non sappiamo
andiamo a tentativi
e scattato un ambulanza e sta zona non
so come si fa a riparare aiuto
avrei dovuto guardare il tutorial
l'unica cosa che ho capito che quando la
visuale miwa nera è perché c'è una
ventola che non funziona io devo andare
a ripararla ok questo beep beep fisso
quindi sticazzi mica roba che ho capito
ve la spiego
per come l'ho capita io è che le ventole
dopo un po si rompono salve e tu devi
andare a ripararla perché se non la
ripari diventa tutto scuro perché per di
ossigeno quindi devi imparare le ventole
basta questo ho capito ogni volta che
una ventola si rompe non sai quale si
rompe devi andartelo a cercare tu mentre
stai soffocando ottimo in tutto questo
non ho capito come dovrebbero
come dovrei allontanare sti tizi questo
non l'ho capito
maronna me non potevo fare il
commercialista nella vita io porca vacca
come voi ma dal nulla quindi quindi
quindi adesso ho capito come deviare le
persone semplicemente quando quando mi
stanno per ingrossare la na li devo
tirare la leva bene era chiaro che poi
mi chiami disputando no ti prego dove
dove dove due ok bene per bene una sega
però va bene mi sa bene tutto mi sta
bene che se continuano a crescere le
ventole porca vacca grazie dio avrei più
fare non stavo più leggendo
fantastico salve
non capisco cosa stia dicendo io posso
decidere dove andare di qua problema
buying sono state non fare e molte ok a
scappare velocemente ok ma sono le sedie
il mattino non dormono gli animatronics
anche alle 6 del mattino credo che abbia
detto porca vacca stappare polaroid come
andar bene ma neanche se mi metti i
sottotitoli capisco cosa vuoi che
capisca senza sottotitoli
[Musica]
devo a creare un'unica roba che ho
capito che mi ha detto che devo
hackerare una cassaforte brava a creare
un passaggio
ok next aiuto fare questa cosa nel
mentre che la gente mi uccide che bello
[Musica]
e papà è che devo fà che devo fà che ho
flesciato la faccia più di così non
potevo fare niente se non ho della
difesa capisci continua
porca vacca non a difesa ci ho provato
devo hackerare la cassaforte questa
questa roba quale muovendo il turno
anche online
ok vai vai veloce next varcato mamma ok
ciao
[Applauso]
non ho capito cosa hai detto ma non mi
stai simpatica ho fatto io sto flash
anno ogni tanto non so quando dove
sciaré prova bene
[Musica]
salve aiutò flashato flashato è andato
via mai aveva raggiunto neanche
difficilissima sta roba qua
quante roboante password ma voi siete
pagati no ma con troppe questa girando
con il telefono che cosa sono mister
robot grazie ad una parte difficilissima
rega questa bottini è più difficile il
gioco normale
[Musica]
ok ma stai zitta mancano quattro regate
e andato veloce veloce voce next manca
32 quando il polmone cieli e linee siano
plus a farlo ok
[Musica]
oggi su cristo basta vi prego sono le
sei del mattino fate ne uscì una notte
intera su stop ero dentro e per cortesia
non parlare non ti capisco si concentra
la scusa se vuoi
grazie a dio ho fatto inglese alle
elementari ho capito madonna si completa
sì sì sì sì
fammi andare avanti perché guarda è
stato jean ansia specchi sai
va bene la farò un solo tentativo per la
vittoria ragazzi ma il partente che non
arrivino al corridoio quindi non stare
attento a questa che la sala centrale e
al corridoio giusto se mi vanno giù
l'evento di in questo momento io ce l'ho
nel ca prandini di brutto ciao
sì adesso possono andarci giù le ventole
adesso però è di una vacca bocca
trottola che è successo stanno lì
incredibile io sono morto
forse dovrei stare un attimino zitto ok
va bene perché io sono contento giuro
che vi sia piaciuto sono stato molto più
avanti di quanto pensassi anche perché
faccio pagare gli pena che il 13 invece
stavolta presso la prima partita non è
anche andata malissimo ragazzo va di
sicuro che vi sia piaciuto come al
solito è piaciuto momento non mi piace
anche a vari social che come ogni video
d'ottone descrizione iscrivetevi al
canale se non sta con iscritti nei cda
vanno perseguiti
[Musica]